des applaudissements de l'émotion et le
sentiment du devoir accompli
184 citoyens tirés au sort ont rendu ce
matin leur rapport sur la fin du vie
dans l'hémicycle du Conseil économique
et social durant trois mois ils ont
confronté leur réflexion et auditionner
une soixantaine d'experts
[Applaudissements]
en faveur
le pape François est sorti ce matin de
l'hôpital où il avait été admis mercredi
en raison d'une infection respiratoire
il se présentait vous le voyez debout
manifestement en forme le souverain
pontife a même répondu non sans une
pointe d'humour à quelques questions
comment vous sentez-vous et bien je suis
toujours en vie la personne en fin de
vie devrait donc d'abord faire une
prédemande auprès d'un médecin suivi
d'un délai de réflexion puis d'une
demande officielle écrite ou enregistrée
en cas d'incapacité du patient ce sont
ces directives anticipées qui
prévaudront ou celle de la personne de
confiance qu'il a désignée on lui a posé
quel rapport vous avez à la mort et il a
répondu la mort ça me fait rire donc je
sais déjà ce que je veux sur ma pierre
tombale je veux qu'il y a écrit ne pas
déranger et en tout petit faudra
vraiment s'approcher pour le lire il y
aurait écrit si tu peux lire ça c'est
que tu es en train de marcher sur mes
couilles
je pense que voilà pourquoi elle m'aime
après ma mort
les gens riront les photos paraissent
irréelles pourtant une voiture a bien
fini sa course dans un gymnase une
caméra de surveillance à filmer le
véhicule en plein vol transpercé le mur
du bâtiment situé à Flémalle en Belgique
pour décoller ainsi après avoir heurté
un rond-point la berline de verrouiller
bien au-dessus des 90 km/h autorisés sur
cet axe
[Musique]
en route pour la réponse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du jamais vu pour un ancien président
américain
Donald Trump vient d'être inculpé au
pénal par un grand jury à New York
l'annonce a fait l'effet d'une bombe
politique dans le pays
nous avons une alerte info majeure c'est
même historique l'ancien président
Donald Trump est inculpé par un grand
jury
l'ancien président pourrait faire face à
plus de 30 chefs d'accusation
[Musique]
il est notamment soupçonné d'avoir versé
en 2016 130 000 dollars pour faire taire
une ancienne actrice stormy Daniel's
avec laquelle il aurait eu des relations
et d'avoir fait passer cette dépense au
titre de vrais juridique dans ces contes
de campagne hier soir dans un communiqué
à serbe le millionnaire a réagi
c'est une persécution politique et une
ingérence dans l'élection à un niveau
jamais vu dans l'histoire cette chasse
aux sorcières se retournera massivement
contre Joe Biden vous vous prénommé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
donc vous demande effectivement
d'accueillir le doubleur officiel de
Chewbacca
première question Mariah Carey plus Jim
Carrey ça fait combien d'angles
[Applaudissements]
une tour Eiffel qui perd la tête et des
visiteurs plutôt surpris si c'est pour
des raisons techniques je trouve ça très
bien si on le remet en place après il
faut pas nous changer la Tour Eiffel on
aime si c'est pas long pourquoi pas si
ça dure
c'est moche mais l'illusion n'aura duré
qu'un temps en France on ne touche pas
au monstre sacré ou alors l'espace d'une
visite au parc France Miniature
d'Élancourt dans les Yvelines un premier
avril par exemple loufoque dégoûtante
voire cauchemaresques un internaute a
créé cette vidéo de Will Smith mangeant
des spaghettis via un outil
d'intelligence artificielle et il a fait
des émules depuis d'autres célébrités
sont passées à table et d'autres plats
ont été servis ces vidéos cumulent des
millions de vues comme la preuve que
l'intelligence artificielle a encore de
gros progrès à faire dans la création de
vidéos et non vous ne voyez pas double
une réplique de la Dame de Fer installée
au pied de la Tour Eiffel voilà ce que
l'on pouvait lire sur son avis de
naissance je m'appelle et Féla je suis
né le samedi 1er avril 2023 à 5h25 à
Paris je mesure 32 mètres et pèse 23
tonnes ma maman est folle de joigne
réplique éphémère à l'occasion des 134
ans de la grande dame à admirer jusqu'au
10 avril les enfants
c'est peut-être l'occasion
il fait semblant d'être amical et en
fait il a changé de doigt au dernier
moment oh bah c'est pas la première fois
qu'on nous le lit
au dernier moment il te fâchement de
doigt normalement c'est pas spécialité
dimanche soir on posera un nouveau
numéro de ce beau geste sur France 2
juste après le film beau geste émission
qu'il répète dans cet avocat
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait monsieur
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
moi je crois dans la paix dans le monde
mais ce qui est très intéressant c'est
qu'en astrologie Pluton est rentré en
Verseau saturne est en poissons et il
faut savoir que la dernière fois qu'on
aille plutôt en Verseau il y a eu la
Révolution française c'est à dire que ce
que vous dites ça fait beaucoup écho
parce que aujourd'hui on rentre dans une
énergie ça va durer entre deux ans et
demi et 15-20 ans donc on a le temps ah
oui mais on rentre dans une énergie de
casser les
anciennes règles 3 2 1 2
[Applaudissements]
voilà voilà oui oui là je dis oui je dis
merci France 2 je dis merci le service
public je dis merci à vous